les joyaux du val de loire concentrer
sur deux hectares et voici un quart de
siècle que la recette attire toujours
autant de touristes
quarante mille chaque année à partir du
mois d'avril c'est la plupart du temps
en famille qu'on vient découvrir cette
mise en scène étonnante découvrir tous
les châteaux qu'on veut pas faire en une
seule visite et puis en ayant des
enfants à ces jeunes aussi c'était plus
ludique de les emmener voir chaque
château dans les relais ce matin déjà on
convient d'allier et on va faire le zoo
de beauval et donc vous connais pas très
loin on a profité pour faire les mini
châteaux
tu as fait un peu les voitures et tout
ça jusqu'à mais là on va aller faire les
voitures et avant va finir les châteaux
depuis 25 ans les reproductions ou un
25e étonnent par leur réalisme
la balade est depuis quelques temps
également agrémenté d'un support
numérique à disposition des visiteurs
une tablette pédagogique qui donne un
peu plus de sens encore à la plongée
dans l'histoire apprentissage mais aussi
loisirs pour séduire les plus jeunes
le principe fonctionne toujours le
secret c'est de continuellement de se
réinventer proposé vraiment des espaces
ludiques et permettent à toute la
famille de découvrir ce parquet et
d'après si en fait cette découverte
plus que les maquettes que l'entretien
paysager que l'on a c'est aussi des
zones vraiment de loisirs et qui
permettent aux petits et grands de
découvrir cet espace les amoureux des
jardins y trouvent également leur compte
avec un foisonnement de parterres
fleuris d'arbres et arbustes taillés un
travail rendu difficile par les aléas
climatiques
un printemps humide et un été qui
continue aussi dans l'humidité les
plantes qui fonctionne habituellement en
début de saison n'ont pas fonctionné du
tout même des plantes qui ont pourri on
a dû est obligé de s'adapter
le parc mini châteaux d'amboise sera
ouvert tout l'été et ne fermera ses
portes qu'avec l'arrivée de la toussaint